au petit matin les pompiers
interviennent dans le district de
Disneyland ski dont le nord-est de Kiev
ces immeubles et ses véhicules viennent
d'être touchés par une attaque russe sur
la capitale ukrainienne les frappes ont
fait plusieurs morts dont un enfant
touché par un débris alors qu'il tentait
de rejoindre un abri sa grand-mère
choquée est évacuée par les secours les
habitants eux ont été réveillés par le
bruit des explosions
la frappe s'est produite vers 3 heures
du matin
je me suis réveillé et j'ai vu le feu
ma porte a été défoncée j'ai réveillé ma
mère et on a couru vers le couloir on
est descendu et on est sorti les gens
couraient
les fenêtres étaient cassées et les
balcons détruits selon l'administration
militaire ukrainienne une dizaine de
missiles balistiques ont été tirés jeudi
par l'armée russe en direction de Kiev
les systèmes de défense aériennes les
ont tous interceptés mais en retombant
leur débrisions fait des victimes et des
dégâts cette frappe et la 18e menée par
Moscou contre qui est F1 mois depuis
plusieurs semaines les attaques russes
s'intensifient contre la capitale
ukrainienne dont les habitants vivent au
rythme des sirènes d'alerte et des
explosions dans le même temps l'Ukraine
intensifie ses frappe sur la région
russe de Belgorod les autorités locales
disent avoir commencé l'évacuation
d'enfants de localité frontalière de
l'Ukraine